also wenn man unsere einzigartige
intergalaktische Automobilbranche
sage ich mal kaputt machen wollen dann
müssen wir diesen Weg weitergehen indem
man nur noch sagen Elektro Elektro aber
keiner versteht was ist heißt denn
Elektro wir haben erstens Adi
Infrastruktur nicht dann ist kobal wo
abgebaut wird gerade in Chile und in
andere Länder Menschen werden gequält
Kinder werden kaputt gemacht da sage ich
ganz offen Leute hört auf mit dem Moral
sondern wir brauchen mehrere
Möglichkeiten ah Wasserstoff grüner
Wasserstoff wir könnten unsere Motoren
halten wir haben geile diese Fahrzeuge
saubere Dieselfahrzeuge gemeint ich
jetzt die sind weltweit die besten alles
wo wir sind wo wir gut sind sagen die
Politiker das wollen wir nicht
ebenfalls die sichersten sind ja in
Deutschland nach meinen Erkenntnissen
vielleicht liegt die auch falsch aber
wollen wir auch nicht aber den dreckigen
Atomstrom von Frankreich den wollen wir
jetzt kaufen und ganz teuer machen dass
die Menschen sich nicht mehr finanz
können darum sage ich wir brauchen
wieder Leute die kreativ sind die
Pioniergeist haben Pioniergeist heißt
was will ich neu ohne dass ich die
Menschen und den Staat schade ich bin
der Meinung und das ist meine
persönliche Meinung der die Politiker
die was zu sagen haben Schaden den Staat
mehr als helfen
Automobilindustrie entzogen sitzender
bezogen sitzen da zu viele BWL hat zu
viele Managertypen und zu wenig
Ingenieuren
hat ja Porsche erfolgreich gemacht weil
er nicht ja sage ist sondern weil er das
gemacht hat was er für richtig fand und
wir brauchen wieder Manager die einfach
Entschuldigung dass sie sagt wieder Eier
in der Hose haben zu sagen das will ich
machen und nicht ja sage und ich glaube
das ist überhaupt
ja es ist abhanden gekommen weil man
nicht mehr gelernt haben zu kämpfen wenn
ich jetzt mal Helmut schmitzi Helmut
kohlsee bin ich draußen sehe das sind
alles noch die Kämpfer gewesen das waren
die Kämpfer die waren vielleicht nicht
mal astrein in Aussage aber du hast
gewusst was Sie gesagt haben
mich mit dem Diesel betrogen hat ne also
der irgendwie würfelt Millionen Menschen
die diese
verwechselst du wieder nein das war
porsche hat nichts gemacht nein war
nicht doch
kein Verfahren
wirst du immer so polnisch überhaupt
von den kleinen Leuten das sind die
kleinen Leute
richtig betrogen worden von einem
Unternehmen aber es sind immer die
Politiker und du tust dich sprechen
der hat Millionen Menschen ganz kurz
nein der hat mit diesen nichts zu tun
andere nicht beschuldigen es waren
andere ermittlungswerfer
frei gesprochen worden hinter vorne
dass du Menschen etwas behauptest was
nicht stimmt
gegen Politik nein nein ich kann es ja
nachweisen so ganz einfach okay haben
wir ein Bildungssystem wo in Ordnung ist
haben wir eine gescheite autostruktur
bei uns haben wir nicht wir haben nichts
und jedes Mal behauptest du immer die
Politiker die sind gerade vom Herrgott
runtergeschickt werden ganz
offensichtlich
nein
können wir vielleicht noch mal ganz
viele abrunden ganz kurz Arbeitsplätze
befürchten sie da könnten
halbe Million bin ich mehr als überzeugt
der halbe wenn wir das so machen würden
wie
Ingenieure die nicht mehr Mut haben zu
sagen das geht nicht so und wenn man
einige Politiker haben die ebenfalls
sagen das geht nicht so wer mehr halbe
Million verlieren
die werden dann alle Bürger Geld
bekommen
ist schon möglich ich bin da muss ich
sagen auch ein großer Sorge wenn man
sieht den Niedergang von General Motors
in den starten wie Detroit im Grunde
jetzt also vollkommen runtergekommen ist
da das ist ja eine ganze Region die da
vollkommen verarmt ist wir haben bei uns
im im südöstlichen Niedersachsen habe
ich Familie die Arbeiten alle irgendwie
bei Volkswagen oder bei den
angeschlossenen Zulieferbetrieben wenn
da der Ofen aus ist oder bricht diese
Region zusammen Stuttgart zum neuen
Detroit jetzt nicht so haben kann ich
auch nicht beurteilen aber was natürlich
ich ich was zu ergänzen weil wir jetzt
immer so sagen wir haben Sie das Problem
durchaus was Sie gesagt haben dass auch
die Unternehmen und die Manager eben in
dem Umfeld in dem wir uns befinden auch
die medialen Umfeld sehr zurückhaltend
sind und dann nicht auf morgen die sagen
halt nicht wir sorgen uns mehr
lieferversorgung sondern die was sie
machen ist die Handeln einfach und im
Gegenteil was Sie gesagt haben schon vor
Corona beispielsweise konnten wir sehen
dass die deutsche Industrie abgewandert
ist also der Anteil der Wertschöpfung
von verarbeitenden Gewerbe sagt man dazu
ist bereits vor Corona gefahren und er
fällt jetzt natürlich beschleunigt durch
den energiepreisschock weiter und die
Firmen wissen wenn ich jetzt Manager bin
ich kann das hingehen kann sagen ich
glaube nicht an die Energiewende wie sie
ist dann werde ich da angefeindet was
weiß ich oder ich investiere halt nicht
in Deutschland investiere woanders und
das ist genau was passiert ich habe
viele Firmen schon einzelne nehmen die
ihre Firmen verkaufen die einfach
aussteigen oder die einfach sagen ich
investiere woanders die gehen die USA wo
Energie in Zetel kostet das passiert
einfach und wir haben dieses Klima und
wir glauben alle diese politische Klima
das mediale Klima und dann auch
gesellschaftlich wo man sagt okay wir
wollen das alle oder zumindest die
Mehrheit haben die Öffentlichkeit willst
es eben das halt Leute hingehen und
sagen Bruder Müller von der SBF hat er
gesagt moment mal hier ganz schwer für
den Standort da gab's recht richtig
Diskussion der will jetzt nur äh ja
Panik machen schaut immer die Gewinner
an der BASF die machen doch total viel
Gewinn ist kein Problem aber natürlich
auch deshalb weil sie im Ausland sind
und jetzt was machen sie 30 % werden sie
in Deutschland abbauen und das kommt
noch nicht mehr wieder und wenn Sie
heute wenn es Marsmännchen geben wird
die Welt es gibt chemische Industrie
noch nicht beispielsweise würde sagen
worauf der weltmark chemische Industrie
Kemal garantiert nicht auf die Idee ist
in Deutschland zu machen und das ist
vergessen wir immer wenn das immer weg
ist es weg es kommt nicht jeder was
bedeutet das für uns was befürchten sie
wenn sie jetzt nicht glauben
aber das Problem es sind
überdurchschnittlich gut bezahlt
Arbeitsplätze und da strahlt halt aus
und wissen Sie wenn wir hinterher nur
noch ähm ich habe hier schon mal gesagt
ich Cappuccino verkaufen das ist zwar
nett aber es ist nicht so Wirtschaft und
das ist das grundlegende Problem und wir
verkennen meines Erachtens die Bedeutung
die eben diese schlüsselindustrieren für
den Wohlstand haben und wenn die erstmal
weg sind wenn sie kaputt sind sind
kaputt und das ist das was ich da bin
weil ich definitiv sehe als massive
gefahren die Unterstützung der Politiker
das ist heute glaube ich unser Liebling
ich glaube seit ich denken kann höre ich
von Unternehmen die abwandern weil die
Bedingungen hier schlecht geworden sind
also das ist ja kein neues Thema aber es
wird vielleicht irgendwann spürbar
vor 25 Jahren auch gesagt das wird jetzt
glaube ich spürbar und jetzt wird es
aber auch spürbar ich glaube das ist
dieser zu spät genau ich glaube ja das
ist diese Fälle gibt ich will ja gar
nicht schwarz-weiß machen sondern ich
glaube das ist in der Tat diese Fälle
gibt ja das ist auch BASF das habe ich
auch gelesen habe ich mich auch mit ein
bisschen beschäftigt ich bin jetzt so
drinnen in der Materie wie sie aber das
Argument das Unternehmen sagen die
Rahmenbedingungen werden schlechte und
wir gehen hier raus das hatten wir bei
der Frage des Mindestlohn all diese
Dinge wird es ja immer wieder
thematisiert diese Drohung ist ja nicht
neu also die kennen wir seit ist die
soziale Marktwirtschaft gibt so von
daher sage ich auch dort immer ein
bisschen Gelassenheit ohne das völlig
aus dem Auge zu verlieren aber keine
Panikmache von wegen die Großindustrie
und der Mittelstand
müssen okay
bin weil ich einfach
eingangs schon mal gesagt ich hatte
Eingang schon mal gesagt ich bin kein
Freund von den einfachen Lösung ich bin
kein Freund ich habe zwei Herrschaften
kommt doch mal runter entspannt euch mal
Atmen bleibt mal ganz locker wird alles
gut werden ich bin kein Freund von
Populismus der das sind alles so Sätze
die hören sich gut an hier Steuer unter
jeder soll 25.000 € kriegen Freiberg für
alle findet jeder Klasse ich auch aber
ich sage im Kontext dessen was ich
beobachtete glaube ich dass wir viele
Probleme haben aber ich glaube dass wir
auch eine gute Nation sind und dass wir
stark sind und ich habe gesehen auch
unsere Vorgängerregierung das hat gar
nichts mehr jetzigen Regierung zu tun
hat uns auch durch einige Krisen in den
letzten Jahren durchgeführt
Energiekrise verschuldet keine kam dazu
aber es war doch polierte immer gesagt
wir sind das einzige Land der Welt das
aussteigt aus Kohlekraft und Atomkraft
gleichzeitig und die ganze Welt wird uns
freuen das war Quatsch die Welt ist uns
nicht gefolgt
was mir nicht gefällt ist die
Unterstellung ständig immer es ist in
Deutschland erlaubt dass meine andere
Meinung hat absolut immer die andere
Meinung ist man nicht in kaputter
sondern man hat es man und es nennt man
Toleranz ja aber wieder nichts dagegen
arbeiten
ganz einfach ich habe wir leben in eine
Transformation ich habe noch nie von
Abwanderung geredet sondern ich habe
gesagt die
Schlüsselprodukte wo man haben tun die
Politiker kaputt machen also mit einer
sagte Diesel ist schlecht wir machen die
besten Diesel wir machen nicht die
Benziner die Benziner machen die
Osteuropäer das muss man einfach wissen
wir haben so viele gute Technologie
Antriebstechnik Wasserstoff seit Jahren
sagen wir wir wollen grünen Wasserstoff
haben dann kommt irgendein Prediger der
ist irgendwie ausgebildet worden von
irgendeinem Paps der sagt nee wir
brauchen Elektro alle gehen auf Elektro
die sind so der elektrolysiert das ich
sage nein und jetzt kommt vielleicht
Fehler
Auto ist kein Fehler aber zu 100 % ist
ein Fehler also wenn man sagt nur noch
Elektro ist ein Fehler das ist ein Teil
der Lösung ist ja das sind Teil
Wasserstoff ja das ist ein Teil Diesel
ja immer ein Teil sage ich und das muss
ich erst ergeben und davon habe ich
hohen Respekt dass man unsere gute
Automobilbranche kaputt machen aber
nicht kaputt machen weil man dumm sind
sondern weil man das politische und die
Wirtschaft jetzt bin ich nicht polemisch
darfst du nicht politisch sehen sondern
betriebswirtschaftlich und das machen
wir nicht mehr und das ärgert mich
granademäßig und wenn ich manchmal
übertreibe mache ich das bewusst um
jeden mal das Licht anzumachen in der
Dunkelheit wo wir uns jetzt befinden
gar nicht mehr hören denn bald fahren
wir vielleicht alle Radl uh jetzt sind
sie alle still oha wären wir gleich hier
bei 8:15 Uhr kurze Pause bis gleich